one of the nation's largest wireless
providers is set to release new
technology to stop Robo callers from
reaching your phone this technology
cannot come fast enough Verizon is
reportedly said to offer customers free
spam blocking tools by the end of the
week
Yahoo Americans received an estimated
forty seven point eight billion robo
calls in the year 2018 more than 46
percent of those were from scammers and
a Warner shows us the wireless
industry's efforts to hang up on
unwanted calls and a good morning good
morning Verizon announced in January
that it would ultimately offer free call
blocking tools that month alone there
were nearly 5.2 billion
robo calls a historic high now Verizon
already offers a premium surface call
filter that includes spam detection and
reporting features for roughly $3 a
month it says it will now offer some of
those features for free this is part of
a national push to meet FCC protocols
that allow carriers to verify calls with
a digital fingerprint and weed out
potential spoofed phone numbers AT&T and
Comcast announced last week they
successfully conducted caller
verification tests using the FCC
guidelines in November t-mobile took us
behind the scenes of its Robo caller
crackdown we saw its scam ID program
which helps customers screen and block
problem calls a company vice president
called efforts to stop scammers an arms
race FCC Chairman Ajit PI has urged the
nation's carriers to uniformly adopt the
robo call protocols by the end of the
year last month he threatened regulatory
intervention if they failed to meet that
deadline viana this is all music to my
ears cannot happen soon enough
Anna thank you stop calling us